welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Colonel Timothy McAteer a military
postgraduate fellow at Yale University
he's here on a year-long appointment to
the Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
Colonel McAteer is an active-duty
US Army infantry officer with 23 years
of service the majority of his service
has been as a paratrooper with the 82nd
Airborne Division he has multiple
tactical and operational level
deployments ranging from rifle platoon
leader in Desert shield/desert storm and
the Sinai Egypt up through service as a
battalion and division operations
officer and command at the battalion
level in Afghanistan and the brigade
level in Haiti and Iraq today we talked
with Colonel McAteer about his role as a
military fellow at Yale welcome colonel
McAteer Thank You Marilyn it's great to
be here today so let's begin with an
overview of the program tell us about it
and how and how you became interested in
it well I'll start with a quick overview
of the Army's professional military
education program which the fellowship
falls into at the later stages for
officers you start with
pre-commissioning training about your
fifth year in the Army you get pulled
out of the active force go into a
schoolhouse institution environment and
that's where you learn about staff
functions and company level command
halfway through your career in the army
about your tenth or eleventh year as a
major you'll go to the command and
General Staff College which is higher
level staffs and then the last stage
around 1920 years you go to what is
known as Senior Service College the
fellowship is in lieu of the Senior
Service College so I will get senior
service college credit by being a fellow
here at Yale most of my
coworkers or other officers in the army
and senior service college or at one of
the various service war colleges that
said though there are about 90 army
fellows throughout the nation right now
in colleges and think tanks and then
some informed foreign nations at their
staff colleges we have fellows at
Harvard MIT Georgetown and University of
Texas we have fellows at the Brookings
Institute CSIS the center for new
American security down in DC and then we
have fellows in Pakistan and France and
the UK so particularly though for here
Yale the fellowship program here as you
stated earlier is it Jackson that's
where my one year appointment is and
that program is one year it's non-degree
producing it gives me credit for the
senior service college and my role in
Jackson is - well I attend an audit
courses that I that I am interested in
and I also focus my studies in the in
the global affairs program the grant
strategy program international relations
program kind of my interest and that
keeps me tied in with the War College
I've been assigned a faculty mentor at
Jack Jackson because I also have
research and writing requirements that I
will send back to the War College and
they'll kind of check off and say okay
you've completed your requirements for
research of a topic that is of interest
and importance to the army what is that
well right now I'm still in the process
of developing a research question but
I'm focusing on Middle East North Africa
I think and some of our policies there
as you look around today when the events
in in Libya and then in northern Africa
after the Arab Spring and how they
relate to our foreign policy and
recently in the last couple years the
military's established Africa Command
which is a regional geographic combatant
command focused on the continent so
they're all relevant topics as we look
at the military instrument of power
being employed in northern Africa so
that's what I'm looking at okay and why
did you choose to come to Yale versus
doing the service school program well a
lot of reasons you have to compete first
of all so you put in a list of
preferences and kind of cross your
fingers I leaned heavy towards going to
a college university setting for a
couple reasons
personally I felt it was important at
this stage of my career to maybe not
that the army or the service schools are
not helpful but to get away from an
environment where I'm very comfortable
and be immersed into an education
environment that takes me out of my
comfort zone
and I think Yale has already started to
do that in many ways also the access to
the intellectual capital that an
institution like Yale has is unequaled
anywhere in the United States the
program here you know is only two years
old and I might have mentioned that
before I'm only the second fellow here
and and it's interesting the way the
culture is changing a little bit Yale
with respect to the military right we
just allowed the ROTC to come back on
campus
I believe maybe a year or two ago and
I'm not quite sure of the timing but
fairly recently right yeah both Air
Force and Navy have programs here a
little disappointed that the army didn't
one of the things I'm not here to do
though Yale is to recruit and try to get
people into the military I'm here to
that's more of a personal enlightenment
kind of it is it is and then I also
believe that I have something to
contribute to the classroom as well
right let's talk about that a little bit
what do you think that you can
contribute well I think I bring a little
bit different perspective on on some
global affairs from a very practical
experience level I've been deployed
multiple times at various levels from
the tactical operational a strategic
level you know this training program the
the War College or Senior Service
College fellowship is designed to get me
to think at the strategic level so I'm
learning a lot in that but as I've
learned in a lot of the class
this grant strategy and some of the
international relation classes that I
attend there's a lot of interest in Iraq
and Afghanistan and how the military as
an instrument of national power is
employed and I feel like I can give some
real-world practical experiences to
contribute to the dialogue within the
classroom can you think of one
particular example of where you actually
contributed something that you
experienced I was able in one of the
great programs here is the grant
strategy program with Professor Gatos
professor Hill professor Kennedy and I
have the great honour of receiving with
a panel including those gentlemen
marshal briefs from from the students
and these marshal briefs our grand
strategy briefs that they've developed
and then they present them to us and I
always play a senior DoD official so I
can give the Department of Defense's
position on their strategy towards let's
say the Middle East I just said through
one that was the revitalizing Europe and
the relationship of the United States in
Europe and and the defence structure in
Europe so what I was able to offer when
we talked about the particulars of that
student-led proposal was the the
concerns of the military in terms of
basing in terms of reduction of forces
and places that you know we might feel
are a little more important where they
had had through their readings thought
well this would be very easy to do and I
was able to give them I think a dose of
reality in the application of their
strategy prior to you coming to this
program I know your active duty where
were you stationed and what were you
doing for the last ten years I've been
at Fort Bragg and for the last ten years
I've been very involved in well the two
wars that we've been involved with I've
been engaged with I started out coming
out of that mid-level school that I
mentioned earlier the command and
General Staff College and I was able to
attend a second year at Fort Leavenworth
we like to call Fort Leavenworth the
intellectual center of the army
they're in Kansas but it is and that's
our schoolhouse at the advanced military
Studies program which gave me access to
jobs that it might not have gotten
before and I became a planner at the
division level as we were going into
Iraq in 2003 so that gave me a lot of
exposure it's a lot of hard work but
that gave me a lot of exposure into how
operations are really put together on a
grand scale and from that job I served
in a battalion level which is an
infantry battalion about 800
paratroopers in the 82nd and deployed to
Afghanistan deployed again to Iraq came
back and then I just kind of worked my
way up through the division I ended up
commanding a battalion in Afghanistan
for 15 months doing primarily
counterinsurgency operations in two
pretty large provinces inside of
Afghanistan and what does that actually
mean counterinsurgency what do you do
well counterinsurgency is it's an
interesting operational concept and
there's a lot of debate in the military
but it has proven to be fairly effective
when dealing in post-conflict type
environments when we finished in early
2001 2002 the Taliban were defeated in
Afghanistan and you know was this influx
of more conventional forces to try to
consolidate the gains and then the
mission as you know in Iraq in both
Afghanistan they started to evolve a
counter insurgency has a component of it
which could be considered
nation-building but it's a it's a an
operation that is very population
century where you you were trying to
build the security forces and the
capability security forces within the
nation the host nation so you're working
with them to help them do that
absolutely so we do partnered operations
with their military with their police
and but the centerpiece of the strategy
is the population is protecting the
population from insurgents who are
trying to destabilize the situation it's
extremely complex
a times be very dangerous but it can
also be very very rewarding when you
start to see the progress in security
forces when you start to see local
economies and the populations starting
to flourish when you start to see
schools open children girls in the in
those nations in particular starting to
get an opportunity for an education in
some some places but it's very difficult
and then the goal always a
counterinsurgencies to eventually turn
over operations to the nation and then
depart it takes a very long time and
there's a point in counterinsurgency
it's a crossover point where their
security forces become capable enough to
do independent operations not just
tactically but also operationally
through logistics and command and
control primarily so they can control
and sustain their forces and that takes
a very long time and then my last job
was as a brigade commander I took
command in Haiti right after the
earthquake the brigade had deployed
there I left Afghanistan
showed up in Haiti took command I was
there for a couple of months and that
was extremely rewarding rewarding
operation and then back to Fort Bragg
and then we were the last Brigade in
Iraq that operated in Anbar and Baghdad
provinces and then we redeployed back in
December so this time last year I was in
in Iraq came home in late December and
then prepared to come to Yale so what
are you hoping to ultimately take away
from your experience here yeah what I've
discovered you know you asked earlier
what what I bring to the program and I
think diversity is probably the one word
that would sum up what this experience I
think I bring a diverse set of ideas and
views to the institution but more
importantly and what I think I'll take
away from here is I've been exposed to
very diverse and different points of
view often from some very young and
intelligent extremely intelligent and
driven students here yeah I'm very
impressed by the students and the
faculty but primarily
undergrad and graduate students that
I've been in contact with Yale will
produce and has produced and will
continue to produce senior policy
officials within our nation
I think if I can impart on them a little
bit of a better understanding on the
military instrument of national power in
my short time here and then they can
impart on me
a different way of looking at the same
problems and broaden my horizons a
little bit broaden my understanding from
a civilian perspective I think that's
very important because ultimately the
military rightly so I mean we work for
our civilian leaders day in and day out
so that dialogue is critically I know
you've been here only a short time but
in that time have you have any of your
views been changed on on anything that
you you know had previously thought no
III I think I'm I'm learning to be a
little more of a critical thinker you
know over the last ten years we've
worked out of our comfort zone a lot a
lot of interagency work a lot of work
with the State Department with
nongovernmental organizations that that
five or six years ago would have been
almost unheard of with military and and
the drivers of that or really our our
junior officers and our noncommissioned
officers our 20s you know mid 20 or 30
level leadership in the army
I was on a little bit of the tail end of
that but you quickly learned how
important it is that we we do our best
to speak with one voice we have unity of
effort in our operations but interagency
employment of all the instruments of
national power are critically important
and so you have a good environment here
to develop those skills so a particular
case probably not but I definitely you
know you you can't help but sit in some
of these classes with with the the
professor's that are here and and not
get a you sit in awesome times at their
level of understanding and the depth of
their understand
on the topics that they discussed
whether it's national strategy or or
economics or the study of social theory
and political science and and it it's
forced me to be a lot more I think
critical of my thinking maybe a little
more skeptical of some of the things
that I've heard outside of the military
so in that regard has been very helpful
and what are your plans once you
complete your fellowship here it's hard
to tell I'll go back into the active
force I mean I'm still active yes but
I'll go back to work one of the
beautiful things here is you know six
months ago I was responsible for 3,700
paratroopers in a brigade with six
battalions Wow and now I'm responsible
for myself it's humbling sometimes when
you're when you command an organization
at large - - huge number of people it is
and and and when you're the commander
that you know you kind of people tell
you what you want here and they they
give you the things that you you want
when you ask for me but here I have none
of that
so it's humbling at times and it's it's
important to remember that but I will go
from here and go back into the active
force I could potentially end up on the
Joint Staff down in DC I could go to one
of the combatant commands either PACOM
out in the Pacific or AFRICOM which is
responsible for Africa but headquartered
in Germany right now or potentially I
could go back to Afghanistan now do you
get to do any to have a voice in where
you go or basically are just sent to
where they tell you to go very little
voice needs the of the army come first
they work with us but at the end of the
day we go where we're told to go and and
serve to the best of our ability
wherever we end up okay well this has
been very enlightening thank you so much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work well I appreciate the
opportunity if I could just to finish
this all right
the one thing I'd like to add is is you
know I'll be followed by another fellow
next year we are available resources for
anybody that wants to bring us into
discussion lectures panels
and not to just promote a military
standpoint but to offer a military stash
another viewpoint another viewpoint and
so we're here and we're willing to help
in any way possible and participate in
any way possible good to know thank you
very much for being here Thank You
Marilyn okay for more information about
colonel McAteer please visit our website
at Yale edu backslash Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale